consider the graph of the function f of
x that passes through three points as
shown so these are the three points and
this curve in blue is f x
identify which of the statements are
true
so they give us these statements let's
see this first one says f of negative a
is less than one minus f of negative a
over a so this seems like some type of a
bizarre statement how do we able to
figure out whether this is true from
this right over here so let's just go
piece by piece and see if something
starts to make sense
so f of negative a where do we see that
here well this is f of negative a this
is the point this is the point x equals
negative a so this is negative a
and this is y is equal to f of negative
a
so this is f of negative a right over
here and what we can what we know about
f of negative a based on looking at this
graph is that f of negative a is between
0 and 1. so we could write that 0 is
less than f of negative a
which is less than 1. so that's all i
can deduce about f of negative 8 right
from the get-go
now let's look at this crazy statement 1
minus
1 minus f of negative a
over a what is this
well let's think about what happens if
we take the secant line we're trying to
find the slope of the secret line
between
this point and this point if we wanted
to find the average rate of change
between the point negative a f of
negative a and the point zero one if
this is our endpoint our change in y
our change in y
is going to be
1 minus f of negative a so 1 minus f of
negative a is equal to our change in y
our change in y and our change in x
our change in x going from negative a to
zero so change in x is going to be equal
to zero minus negative a which is equal
to positive a so this right over here is
essentially our change in x over our
change in y from this point to this
point it is our average it is our
average rate of change from this point
to this point
so it is our average rate of change or
you could say it's the slope of the
secant line so the secant line would
look something like this
something
something like
this
slope of the secant line so this right
over here is slope
of
secant
secant line
between
from
from negative a f of negative a
to
zero comma one
so just looking at this diagram right
over here what do we know about this
slope and in particular can we make any
statements about that slope relative to
say 0 or 1 or anything like that
well let's think about what what a line
of slope 1 would look like
well a line of slope one especially one
that went through this point right over
here would look something like
would look something like this
a line of slope one
would look
something like this so this line right
over here that i've just drawn that goes
from negative one comma zero to zero one
this has slope one so this slope is
equal to one
so this green line has a slope of one
does this blue line have a slope it
clearly has a different slope is that
slope is it is this blue line steeper or
less deep than the green line
well it's pretty clear that this this
secant line is steeper than the green
line it's increasing faster so it's
going to have a higher slope so this
looking at it from this diagram this
blue line has a slope higher than one or
the slope of the secant line from
negative a f of negative a to zero comma
one that is going to be greater than one
so this thing right over here is greater
than 1. so we're able to do so this
thing right over here is less than 1
this thing over here is greater than 1.
so this thing is less than that thing so
this must be true
now let's look at this one we're
comparing the slope of the secant line
we're comparing the slope of the secant
line that we just looked at so this is
the same value right over here so we're
comparing this slope
right over here to what's this f of a
minus 1 over a well this is the slope of
this secant line this is the slope of
this secant line that i'm drawing in
this let me do it a more contrast let me
do it in orange
that is the slope of
this
of this secant line
the slope of this secant line so which
one has a higher slope
well it's pretty clear that the blue
secant line has a higher slope than this
orange secant line but here it's saying
that the blues slope is lower than the
orange so this is not going to be true
so this is not true
then finally let's look at this over
here f of a
minus f of negative a over 2a
so they're now complete
they're now this is the slope let me
draw this so this right over here
this is the slope of the secant line
between
this point
and this point right over here our
change in y is f of a minus f of
negative a our change in x is a minus
negative a which is 2a so this is the
secant line right over here so let me
draw it
so this secant line
the secant line right over here
so they're comparing that slope
to
this slope f of a minus 1 is our change
in y over a is our change in x so we're
comparing it to that one right over
there and you could immediately eyeball
this kind of brownish maroon i guess
it's kind of a brown color this this
this secant line that goes all the way
from here to here is clearly steeper
than this one right over here and we
know that the average rate of change
from here to here is going to be higher
than the average rate of change from
here to here because at least from
negative a to zero we were increasing at
a much faster rate and then we slow down
to this rate so the average over the
entire interval is definitely going to
be more than this than the what we get
from zero to a
so this one is also not true this has a
higher we actually know that this is
false if this both of these would have
been true if we swapped these signs
around if this was a greater than sign
if this is a greater than sign so this
is the only one that applies